so I am mr. opened new facility by 2020
so at the moment we're looking for the
correct facility in the London area
there's been a bit of MIS reporting this
morning of the number of jobs so it's
150 new jobs in 800 existing once
supported yeah that's correct so what
we're doing is we're creating 150 new
job for highly skilled scientists in a
state-of-the-art discovery lab but we'll
be taking the opportunity to co-locate
our UK headquarters at the same site as
well so bringing 850 staff who currently
work either in Hoddesdon in our UK
headquarters and we also have a European
clinical research hub based in Kings
Cross at the moment so we'll all be
co-located in the one facility see some
people say this is all being announced
as part of the government's wider
industrial strategy project today which
is all about rejuvenating the whole of
the UK and oh here we go it's more jobs
in London
well there are other sites that you
could have looked at well I think our
presence as a company does extend across
the UK so we already have a
manufacturing facility in chromatin in
the North East and a large animal health
facility in Milton Keynes so we do have
a pan UK presence but for Discovery
Science in particular we wanted to be
located in the London area to really
take advantage of the Golden Triangle
and the Oxford Cambridge and London I
suppose scientific centre of excellence
so that's the reason that we really want
to be in London for this specific
investment and 150 new jobs do we have
the skills base in the UK are these
going to be people from within the UK or
you can have to cast your net further
afield I'm sure it'll be a mixture of
both so what we're looking for is the
brightest and the best new scientists to
come and join our organization MSD has a
legacy and inventing new meds and we
really have a huge focus on discovery
and we pride ourselves to be a research
based pharmaceutical company so we'll be
looking for the brightest and best
scientists wherever they come from and
he's saying how much this is going to
cost you in total this investment not at
the present time no so obviously we're
still in commercially sensitive
negotiations around that what we will
say is if it's a significant investment
for our company so that's quite a thumbs
up for the UK at a time when a lot of
people are saying all how long you know
the UK may lose some of its competitive
edge post brexit I mean brexit clearly
hasn't had any sway and in this decision
whatsoever I think breaks it's an
important consideration for the whole
industry and there's
you know lots of challenges that brexit
is going to pace on the industry as a
whole but for this specific investment
we needed a strong science base and you
know the scientific innovation that's
built up in lakhs London and Cambridge
and Oxford has taken years to come and
it'll take a long time but other places
to catch up so at least in the next
twenty to thirty years we believe that
the science base here will be highly
competitive and that's why I've decided
to invest in London today and have you
had any kind of reassurances or
undertakings from the government I mean
clearly posts the referendum we had
people on this and saying that they
received all sorts of commitments from
the government have you know so I can
categories categorically state we
haven't had a deal with the UK
government obviously before we make any
investment in any market we engage with
a wide variety of stakeholders across
the whole ecosystem so researchers some
government government departments but
absolutely no No Deal has been made
between our company and the government